most Star Trek bands can agree that
there are few characters in the series
quite as revered as the next generations
Captain jean-luc Picard isn't there
something else you have to do now we've
finally gotten some concrete news on
Patrick Stewart's return to Starfleet in
Star Trek by car while the producers of
Star Trek Picard have been surprisingly
forthcoming with info regarding the
series mums the word on when exactly the
series will be beaming onto the CBS all
access streaming platform that will come
as a bit of a bummer for die-hard Picard
fans who have been waiting since 2002's
disappointing tenth Star Trek movies
Star Trek nemesis to see what's become
of their beloved captain but even if the
exact premiere date of Star Trek Picard
was not revealed on that paul h
information dump at san diego comic-con
the show's producers did unveil the full
trailer for the series which promises
that Picard will once again boldly go
where no man has gone before sometime in
2020 plenty of time to run through all
of TNG again and even knock out a little
Deep Space 9 as well maybe skip the
movies though TNG is timeless but the
feature-length follow-ups they have an
age that well so far we've got two
glimpses of the Picard series a brief
teaser and a more involved trailer just
a few months later the teaser took us
back to the cards Family Vineyard which
he retired to sometime after the events
of TNG implying that the show would be
picking up more or less where the series
left off movies not included the full
trailer doubled down on the old man
Picard concept giving us a substantial
peek of the surprising things in store
for the Starfleet iconic there's a lot
to unpack in the trailer including some
unanswered questions
it seems that Picard will begin the
series in retirements making wine in the
French countryside but he's called back
to duty to help a mysterious and
possibly dangerous young woman whose
story somehow leads him back to the
hallowed halls of Starfleet
one of the most pressing questions on
the minds of TNG fans when the news of
the Picard series broke was when exactly
the series would take place 5000 years
in the future it's been almost 20 years
since we last saw a card in the bridge
of the enterprise in 2002 with TNG
cinematics juan's on Star Trek nemesis
no one's favorite Star Trek movie when
we last left the crew they'd narrowly
escaped a galactic beatdown at the hands
of the ruthless Picard clone Shinzo
they'd also seen Jonathan Frakes as Will
Riker leave the enterprise
to take command of the USS Titan and
witnessed the tragic demise of brent
Spiner x' data matching up with the real
lifetime gap the picard series will take
place about two decades after the events
of nemesis the years away may not have
been particularly kind to Shawn Luke who
seems more than a little haunted in his
retirements with apparently no one but a
new pet dog keeping him company so it's
probably good news for Picard that the
peculiar young woman shows up and sets
him on a more adventurous path with a
whole new crew to command the card won't
be returning to the bridge of enterprise
with his TNG crew in tow the captain's
former crew are likely still around
they've just moved on to new things and
new adventures in the years since they
worked as Starfleet officers under
Picard's command as it happens Picard
may not be rolling with Starfleet at all
for this new secretive mission while
we're not 100% certain how or if Picard
will return to Starfleet proper we know
that he'll get a new ship to command
evidently with a whole new crew of fresh
faces from Starfleet's next next
generation we don't know much about the
crew yet but there are some talented
actors bringing the characters to life
the new faces include Santiago Cabrera
from big little lies as Cristobal Rios
Alison Pill from Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world as Doctor Agnes jarate Michelle
heard from ash vs. Evil Dead is Rafi
Musa Kerr Harry Treadaway from penny
dreadful Asner eek and newcomer evan
evan gora as the Romulan L nor so you
can rest assured that there will be
plenty of intrigue among the show's
supporting players the show may be
called the card but with a cast like
this it looks like it won't be just
about him we've long suspected that at
least a few ghosts of Star Trek's past
would be making appearances in Picard
the series is first full trailer
confirmed two surprising additions to
the cast TNG's data last seen being
blown to pieces in the cold vacuum of
space and Star Trek Voyager 7 of 9 last
seen well on Voyager needless to say
fans have a few questions about how
these two characters will fit into the
Picard series
mr. man who's looking for answers on one
level the return of brent Spiner 'he's
inquisitive Android makes sense data was
one of TNG's best loved characters who
developed a complex and rich
relationship with the card over the
course of that shows seven seasons but
with the character apparently having
died at the end of nemesis how is he
returning and why it's hinted at the
movies end that the identical Android b4
can access data spur s'en allottee and
memories but is that what's happening in
Picard
I do not know s for seven of nine we
frankly don't have a clue what role show
play in the Picard series because she
and Picard have never shared the screen
before but they both do share the
struggle of having once been a part to
the Borg collective what we do know is
that a Borg ship is predominantly
featured in the trailer so there's the
potential that seven of nine will offer
some insights on the state of performer
collective however she factors into the
card it's nice to have Jeri Ryan back in
character as she was frequently the most
interesting parts of Star Trek Voyager
the robot has been utilized may I leave
now along with Spiner and Ryan we now
know Jonathan del arco will also appear
reprising his role as board Scout Hugh
from the next generation for those who
don't remember Hugh's memorable TNG arc
the board scout was found stranded and
critically injured in deep space he was
brought aboard the enterprise under
protest from Picard and nursed back to
health
Picard initially sought to use Hugh as a
weapon to destroy the Borg once and for
all
but he was surprising ability to
comprehend human individuality led
Picard to cancel his eNOS Idol plans
though he doesn't show up in the trailer
it's been confirmed that TNG alum
Jonathan Frakes will indeed appear on
screen as the Captain Picard's trusted
number one Will Riker he'll also be
directing some episodes of the show you
were correct it's fact
Frakes will also be joined on screen by
Marina Sirtis the Betazoid Deanna Troi
hey anyone know what levar burton gates
mcfadden and michael dorn are up to
because it sure feels like Picard is
trying to get the TNG band back together
perhaps
friend of all the questions raised by
the Picard trailer one of the biggest
surrounds the identity of a whole new
character the mystery woman Picard is
trying to help after a two decade
absence one assumes that not just
anybody could lead Picard back to
Starfleet deepening the mystery the
woman appears to have a particular
affinity for jean-luc she came to me for
help
of course we promptly see her putting
the smackdown on a couple of armed
guards and we also get some ominous
warnings about her from a couple of
characters so we're not entirely sure
how much protection she actually needs
for now that's all we really know about
the new character outside of the fact
that her name is dodge she's played by
actress ISA Briones aside from Abe
Lincoln you'll miss it appearance in
2018 assassination of Gianni Versace
series she doesn't have many big credits
to her name so here's hoping she gets a
chance to make the most of her Star Trek
debut over his legendary career with
Starfleet
Picard went toe to toe with quite a few
antagonist from the domineering board to
the mischievous queue as far as who's
Jean Luc and company will be basing off
against in Star Trek Picard we still
aren't entirely sure but it's tempting
to think it's the Borg we clearly see
one of those dreaded Borg cubes in the
trailer and Picard also has a very
specific pass with the fearsome
collective and appearances by seven of
nine and Hugh would lead us to think the
Borg will figure prominently in whatever
interstellar ruckus Picard finds himself
in twined in but the trailer also gives
us clear shots of what appeared to be
redesigned Romulan warbirds chips from a
species Picard has more than a prickly
past win it will be interesting to see
what ships there have been in the status
quo since the last time we visited the
Alpha Quadrant was jean-luc will record
find himself in another standoff at the
Borg or the Romulans trying to make a
fearsome comeback it shins on back as
well for now we'll just have to wait and
see while Picard is technically picking
up where the next generation left off
the series has more in common both in
its look and behind the scenes with the
other modern-day Star Trek series Star
Trek discovery both series are being
produced by Alex Kurtzman and the shows
are also set to be streaming partners on
the CBS all access platform with Picard
seemingly taking the same stylishly
cinematic approach the Star Trek as
discovery does and star Trek has never
been a series to shy away from a
crossover either many
answer wondering will Picard and Disco's
disparate crews cross paths on the small
screen I'm not certain of that napkin
well CBS may have some sort of crossover
in mind down the road for those two Star
Trek shows it's a safe bet that Picard
and discovery won't intertwine
immediately a lot of that has to do with
the current plot arc of discovery going
into its third season so here's your
spoiler warning if you haven't seen
what's up yet after a head spinning
twist in the season 2 finale that saw
Discovery's crew leap 1000 years into
the future via a time spanning wormhole
the timelines of the two series would
seem to be way too far apart for a
crossover to work not that that stopped
the series in past so while we wouldn't
be surprised if the series collided
sometime down the road it seems likely
that we'll have to wait for Picard to
find it sea legs first maybe in a second
season we might be getting ahead of
ourselves with Picard's first season yet
to have a launch date it's still a
little early to speculate about a
potential season to the series we'll be
starting off with the 10 episode run
following plot threads that have yet to
be fully revealed but though a lot about
the series's nitty gritty details
remains unknown there seems to be a lot
of goodwill for the nostalgia inducing
series considering just how beloved
Picard is as a character for now at
least if things go well for the series
and the show goes over with fans there's
every reason to think a second season is
in the cards but part of that decision
rests on the fans and how audiences
respond to the series web viewers
respond well to seeing Picard take to
the stars again or they end up feeling
like everyone should have just let the
guys stay retired
either way the show's fate is in your
hands if you want the card to continue
on after these initial episodes you'll
have to make it so you are a truly
clever person check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about star tracker coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]